hey guys my name is jessica roth and i'm
harry shum
jr and we are the stars of all my life
and we're here with buzzfeed to find out
how well we know one another
oh one another already messing it up
here are the rules only check off the
questions you answer correctly about
your co-star
uh-oh but what if i ask really nicely if
you ask really nicely
maybe but probably not
right but at the end you'll get a score
share your score with your partner and
whoever has a high score wins
i got my game place on here very
competitive and i
am as well so game mode first time
you met was actually when you came in
and auditioned for delilah
that's right that's right it was right
you're right
that was just a really quick in and out
though that was really fast
you were incredibly uh lovely and
charming and talented in that audition
and when you came in for all my life you
just
knocked it out of the park so oh you're
so sweet
i'm only sweet when it's true really
really met
when we did the chem read a chemistry
read for all my life
we walked up to each other we gave each
other a hug and we just went down this
like really dark deep scene that you
always do when you first meet someone
it was just lovely i mean just the fact
that i felt like i knew you for a long
time
just moments after meeting you i'll give
that to you for first time we truly met
when is my birthday i'm gonna say your
birthday and i'm gonna be incredibly
wrong i'm just going out there
8 11 9 83
no so wrong
and i know all of the ways not one
single part of that
is right what is my birthday oh god
what's two plus two
four the fourth of january
i gave you an opening it's uh 4 28. or
28. but i'm a 28. i'm 5 28.
we're so bad we're really bad we should
know this but now we know it's time to
ask each other what our birthdays was
cause
yeah we were too involved we were acting
what is my astrology sign
your astrology sign is taurus
and i know that because both of my best
friends are born at the beginning of may
and they're both tauruses but i'm
something else
i only know like pisces uh i'm so bad
i am a gemini gemini yes i knew that i
knew that you knew it
what is my hometown denver colorado
yes that is where i was born correct
mine's hard
because i have a couple but yes costa
rica
and san francisco is where you grew up
were you born somewhere else i was born
in costa rica well you were going to
costa rica okay
costa rica san francisco at that point
you'd get that point
what's my middle name it's not ann it is
anne but with an
e like anne of green gable oh i'm not
gonna get this but it's my middle name
do you just not have a middle name my my
parents didn't know anything about
they're like what's a map
yeah do i get that point for you
your favorite snack at crafty you were
always so good at being healthy
would you eat a lot of apples with
peanut butter
really yeah you're right is yours the
kelp
seaweed or not the kelp but like the
seaweed snacks yeah
i was always very excited when those
were there i think i will count that as
a correct answer because the real
correct answer is all of it
all of the snacks what is my dressing
room must-have
notting hill playing on repeat yeah
that is the correct answer it was not
always there but that was correct your
dressing room must have
music like a sound system yes the rain
full-on dance party okay what is my
coffee order
you don't drink coffee you drink tea
yeah killing it did you drink like a
latte thing
yes yes okay with almond milk
yes was it a double latte vanilla latte
i think that's
a latte what was my go-to activity
between filming scenes
your go-to was to mingle i felt you were
a mingler you went to different crew
members and you're like always talking
is that was that an activity that's
totally an activity
i think your activity was you would
dance a lot you also brought your
theragun around
giving people massages with your
theragun yes i would strike people with
my theragun
in a very loving way nice loving way a
previous
project they worked on before all my
life crazy rich asians
definitely but also you had done
aquafina maybe most recently yeah
aquafina's tv show yeah right before
utopia and delilah um
yes yeah baby what is my partner's name
eric yup and otis yes and shelby
yeah favorite scene that we shot
together for you i
think maybe was the fight yeah even
though it was super emotional
we got to like pull out our punches we
just got to vary it up and just go all
over the place and then finally hone it
down that was just it was emotional and
cathartic like it was
a misrelease i think your favorite is
the fountain
yes that's so true your favorite movie
or
tb i don't know and i i don't know
and you all of them you love you are a
cinephile
it's okay it helps me because that means
i'm getting closer to winning
my favorite uh movie is probably singing
in the ring
that makes sense that makes sense yours
is
love actually no no i love that movie
my most recent favorite movie is the
favorite so we both fail but we both win
because we love good movies first
job i feel like it was a music video
that you were in yeah i want to say
janet jackson and i do not think that's
true
you would never guess the name right
it's literally an artist that
called back to back it was just these
twins that had a small music video you
wouldn't
guess that but you i would give you that
i think you should have that
was it a waitress it was as a waitress i
was a waitress at the original pancake
house
flipping some pancakes serving up the
bacon what is my pet's
name correct and yours is charlie
yes hidden talent i think your hidden
talent is your
amazing ability to put everyone at ease
and to defuse stressful situations
dancing you're also an amazing dancer
which is not a hidden talent at all but
i feel like you infuse like
interesting movement into unexpected
places
your hidden talent is being funny
without
realizing that you're being funny like
that i think that is there's a talent
you're like you're being
you're being hilarious without just like
what what am i doing
eric would agree with you except that
caveat he would add is when i'm trying
to be funny i'm not funny at all
it's only when like i don't know so
joke's on me
all the time i got
14 out of 16
13 out of 16 son of a mom oh
champion it's only because i know
astrology
thank you so much buzzfeed be sure to
catch up in all my life
available on december 4th yes go watch
it